well my friends we are getting
dangerously close to the 2022 midterm
elections debates are in full swing we
have multiple debates uh that I will be
live streaming this week and next week
and the week after and I want to start
today with three important races where
we have either a debate to talk about or
a public appearance or something we will
first talk about Texas governor which is
incumbent Republican Greg Abbott versus
Democratic Challenger Beto O'Rourke we
will then talk about Republican senator
from Florida Marco Rubio the incumbent
against the Challenger democratic
congresswoman Val demings who is uh uh
won the Democratic primaries and is now
facing Marco Rubio and then we will talk
about a very important race Pennsylvania
gubernatorial where the Democratic
candidate Josh Shapiro is facing off
against the Republican uh nominee of
Doug mastriano and mastriano is one of
the most dangerous and extreme
candidates and he is also cuckoo for
Coco Puffs but we will get to that let's
not get to the Cocoa Puffs right away
start with Greg Abbott we did a live
stream on YouTube tuition Facebook last
week of this debate the debate is the
incumbent Republican governor of Texas
Greg Abbott against the Challenger Beto
O'Rourke and we actually did learn a lot
about Greg Abbott during this debate
including uh undeniable confirmation
that Abbott is a completely disgusting
and a completely immoral and dishonest
person which is sort of like the
trifecta for republicans in 2022. let's
start with the first clip in this clip
you will see Greg Abbott when presented
with the reality about abortion in the
world he says listen you know we're
trying to get people baby supplies so
you don't really need access to abortion
when you've got baby supplies do you is
Plan B the alternative when it comes to
somebody who is pregnant from rape or
incest
well it depends on what you mean by
alternative an alternative obviously is
to do what we can to assist and Aid uh
the victim and that is to help get them
medical assistance that they need and
the care that they need but also uh to
know what their options are they're
gonna to know that the state uh
throughout our alternatives to abortion
program provides living assistance baby
supplies all kinds of things that can
help them also we've increased funding
for prenatal and postpartum care thank
you listen guys if you are and I
shouldn't say guys because it's not guys
listen if you are in the situation where
uh you are raped by a family member and
you become pregnant sure you might think
that what you want is to decide for
yourself with the Council of medical
professionals that you might want to not
carry that pregnancy to term we have
this alternative where we will give you
baby supplies after you're forced to
birth the baby
this is Republicans in 2022 now they
deserve to suffer electoral losses as a
result of this complete and utter
Insanity whether they will is a
different question and I don't actually
know the answer right now also during
this very same debate Greg Abbott got
caught lying just straight up lying here
is Greg Abbott claiming he didn't
coordinate uh that uh rather he denies
that he didn't coordinate these
political stunts where they sent
immigrants to different uh
democratically run cities he just
straight up gets caught lying check this
out Governor I want to talk to you you
talked about uh migrants and the
blessing of migrants many migrant
Advocates and Democratic elected
officials have expressed concerns about
the treatment of migrants being bussed
from Texas to other states and cities
here's New York mayor Eric Adams talking
about that just last week yep and when
we reached out to Governor Abbott and
stated can we coordinate can we identify
you know who's traveling here that we
don't have to guess this they refuse to
do so
the White House has called this a
political stunt Governor Abbott is this
a political stunt and has there been
coordination with the states and cities
these migrants are being taken to and if
not why not you have 60 seconds so this
operation began after meeting with local
officials sheriffs understand how slick
that is he says we have coordinated we
we coordinated with local officials here
in Texas no no no no but Greg the issue
is
why didn't you coordinate with the
people in the cities where you were
sending the migrants he tries to slip
and no we spoke to all sorts of people
here in Texas police Chiefs and County
judges where they were overrun with the
number of migrants that border patrol
had dumped into to their tiny little
communities they needed relief and
busing was one of the ways of providing
them relief and thus began the process
of busting the magnets to cities that
self-identified as sanctuary cities
mayor Adams has never called my office
never talked to anybody in my
Administration and that is a lie we now
have the receipts thankfully Fabian Levy
who is the press secretary to New York
City mayor Eric Adams published emails
with redacted email addresses where you
just very clearly very very clearly see
there are email chains we have one up on
the screen right now they did attempt to
communicate and it was Greg Abbott that
opted not to quickly proven to be a
complete and total lie Beto would have
uh quite frankly a very strong closing
statement and really puts significant
pressure on Abbott on the issue of doing
nothing about Firearms violence in Texas
we'll see you tonight 30 seconds for
your closing statement your time starts
now thank you look I don't think that
Greg Abbott wakes up wanting to see
children shot in their schools or for
the grid to fail but it's clear that
he's incapable or unwilling to make the
changes necessary to prioritize the
lives of our fellow Texans that's why
it's on all of us to make sure that we
have change at The Ballot Box this
November 8th I'll keep your lights on
I'll make sure that I keep your kids
safe we'll reduce property taxes and
we'll prioritize the lives of each and
every single Texan in the state all
right so by the way the debate was a
total disaster in terms of the format
there were times where the candidates
were given 15 seconds to respond to
something
it's you know it's one of these things
where the format becomes an enemy of
itself where in order to stick to this
arbitrary format they completely ruin
the possibility of any deep discussion
on any issue so the the unfortunately we
didn't really learn very much other than
confirming some of the horrible things
we uh suspected about Greg Abbott going
in now one interesting thing
KXAN out of Austin Texas did a focus
group before and after the debate and
they had them watch the debate
the debate itself turned a whole bunch
of that room in favor of Beto O'Rourke
so check this out this is the start and
you'll see them put up the numbers you
guys had a lot to say uh during during
the focus group we were able to track
your reactions in real time
um but before our debate this evening we
pulled you with a couple of questions
and one of the responses that we got we
want to share with you now we have a
Graphic to show you this is how you
voted if we as we okay so
um the way that the focus group voted
before the debate was 40 percent said
they plan to support Greg Abbott 27
percent said they plan to support Beto
and 33 percent were undecided I'm just
going to skip through the two minutes of
stuff that they talk about and just show
you these final results after the uh
debate the Abbott number was at 43
Beto had exploded to 50 support in the
room leaving only seven percent
undecided so that's the good news on the
this race the not so good news is that
the the polling in general isn't very
good for Beto but again the idea is the
debate might change that on average it
is Abbott plus eight looking at official
polling in that race so if you live in
Texas a very important race for you to
vote in let's talk now about Florida
Florida is a state where incumbent
Republican senator Marco Rubio is trying
to Stave off a challenge from a
democratic congresswoman Val demings if
I voted in Florida I would vote for
deming's over Marco Rubio Marco Rubio
appeared on CNN over the weekend he
sounded very very sick hopefully it's
not coveted and just a cold but he
sounded ill and he was confronted about
the fact that in the past he has voted
against funding for other states when
they are hit with a natural natural
disaster but now he wants money for
Florida when it's his State recovering
from Hurricane Ian now to remind
everybody in my audience
I think they all should get the federal
funds for disaster relief but what we're
talking about here is hypocrisy now when
Dana Bash confronts Rubio with this
hypocrisy he tries to pull some weird
pork thing and Dana Bash good for her is
prepared for it and she calls it out for
the lie that it is check this out
Senator you wrote a letter Friday to the
Senate Appropriations Committee asking
for disaster relief dollars for
desperately needed resources to rebuild
Florida communities after Hurricane
Sandy hit Northeastern states in 2012
you voted no on a 50 billion dollar
relief package I know you supported a
smaller version but why should other
Senators vote for relief for your state
when you didn't vote for a package to
help theirs right oh I've always voted
for Hurricane and disaster relief I've
even voted for it without pay Force what
I didn't vote for in Sandy's because
they had included things like a roof for
a museum in Washington DC for Fisheries
in Alaska it had been loaded up with a
bunch of things that had nothing to do
with disaster relief and I wouldn't
support disaster relief efforts I would
never put out there that we should go
use a disaster relief package for
Florida as a way to pay for all kinds of
other things people want around the
country so I think that's the key in
moments like this and then Sandy
unfortunately loaded it up they really
did with a bunch of things that had
nothing to do with Sandy but get ready I
voted for every disaster relief package
especially that's clean and I'll
continue to do so when it comes to
Florida I'll do that again and we'll
make sure that that package is clean it
doesn't have stuff for other people in
there I read the Congressional research
service report last night it sounds like
that roof actually was damaged by the
hurricane and what happened in Alaska
was turns out it wasn't a random roof
Marco the result of another disaster but
in any event my question is about the
future are you telling me that if
hurricane Ian relief contains anything
that smells like pork you'll vote no
sure I'll fight against it having pork
in it oh well that's a different thing
you'll fight against it but you'll vote
for it in this particular case this is
not unique to Rubio not like in Rubio's
defense I mean we're talking about Rubio
because it's Florida he represents
Florida but this is really common over
the last decade on this program it's
been what a dozen times two dozen times
that I've come to you all with peace and
love and tears in my eyes and I've said
to you here is another elected official
from Oklahoma Oklahoma just got hit with
tornadoes this very same Oklahoma
official when it was super storm Sandy
affecting New York and New Jersey they
voted against it and now they're saying
give me the money please we need it for
the people these are hypocrites and
there's dozens of them and it's not
unique to Marco Rubio but Marco Rubio is
the guy running for re-election right
now and checking in on the polling there
it's not great but it's not terrible
Marco Rubio leading Val demings on
average by 2.8 percentage points Within
Reach Within Reach and of course all
these guys and I do mean Rubio and
DeSantis all of a sudden they're
friendly with Biden and they're all in
favor of relief because they don't want
to lose their office because of a
disastrous botched reaction to Hurricane
Ian that's their priority right now all
right third looking at 2022 elections we
go to Doug mastriano now the the context
here is that Doug mastriano is one of
the most unhinged and dangerous top
level uh Republican candidates this
election cycle Doug mastriano wants the
voters of Pennsylvania to make him their
governor we have an alternative who's
just completely uncontroversial and
normal his name is Josh Shapiro he's the
Democrat and if you vote in Pennsylvania
I suggest that you support Josh Shapiro
here is Doug mastriano bravely taking
the position at an event over the
weekend that if he becomes the governor
of Pennsylvania he will ban pole dancing
in public schools and he will ban
pornography in public schools are are
there those things in public school well
it doesn't really seem like it but he's
going to ban them very strongly check
this out and by the way look at the
crowd reaction
day one the sexualization our kids pole
dancing and all this other crap that's
going on will be forbidden in our
schools
[Applause]
on day one all the graphic
pornographic the poor necrophy et cetera
in elementary schools will be will be
pulled out
they're gonna pull it out
on day one and done critical race series
out the window
there it is they don't know what it is
but they sure know how to throw it out
of a window what image does Doug
mastriano have of what happens in
schools like is there a lot of pole
dancing in Pennsylvania elementary
schools it's sort of like I will ban
heroin at lunchtime in our Public
Schools oh wow that sounds that sounds
serious is there heroin being
distributed at lunchtime no no but I'm
gonna ban it right away while you're at
it ban the virus as well and just take
care of that problem fortunately the
polling in Pennsylvania
looks pretty okay right now for Josh
Shapiro on average Shapiro is leading
this radical unhinged Republican by 10.
Shapiro plus 10.2 doesn't mean we stay
home doesn't mean we assume we have it
in the bag but it is looking like if
everybody who says they're going to vote
votes Doug mastriano will be sent back
to wherever he came from and he can work
on issues like pornography and uh pole
dancing in school three of the races we
will talk about many more this week
we'll take a quick break let me know on
Twitter at dpacman what race are you
paying the most attention to
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
with absolutely no delay because I
respect all of you too much to delay any
further let's get right into the wacky
political happenings in Warren Michigan
that took place over the weekend later
we're going to get into Marjory Taylor
Green's latest claim that Democrats are
out there assassinating Republicans
willy-nilly it's not true we'll get to
it a little bit later but where was this
all happening well it was happening in
Warren Michigan because failed former
president Donald Trump dripping wet just
the sweat dripping off of him more
orange than ever visibly scared about
what is his future in this country in
the context of four or more criminal
investigations against them dripping
just slathered
he rallied in Michigan
supposedly in support of a number of
different Republicans he barely spoke
about them as is often the case the
rallies are all about him one such
Republican is Tudor Dixon that's her
name Tudor Dixon and she is getting
crushed right now by the Democratic
incumbent Governor Gretchen Whitmer
despite Trump attacking Whitmer for the
last three years since covet started
Trump starts his rally in Warren
Michigan he now has a new election
hypothesis he claims that a guy named
John James won his Senate race in 2020.
John James lost his Senate race in 2020.
so it's it's not just Trump's election
that now he is lying about
with no basis in fact whatsoever he goes
I think John James actually won now you
might be like no John James isn't a
senator and you'd be right because he
lost
and somebody that I've known for a long
time he did great I think he happened to
win the last election for the Senate I
happened to think he won it by quite a
bit
and now he's way leading he's doing a
fantastic job he's got the John James
lost his election he didn't win had he
won he would be a senator right now
Donald Trump also makes the
extraordinarily disturbing comment that
we will never have a fair election again
in the United States well then why would
anyone vote but I'm afraid we have never
had we and I don't believe I don't
believe we'll ever have a fair election
again wow that's a big statement now
certainly not if Trump has his say I
mean listen were it for Trump had Trump
gotten his way in 2020
the president right now would be the guy
who didn't win anything it would it
would be the guy who not only lost the
popular vote lost so lost the electoral
vote he would be president right now so
when they say things like this what we
should hear is them saying if it's up to
us there will never be a fair election
in this country again uh Donald Trump
then still not really knowing much about
dogs listen to what he has to say about
dogs so think of it they're against all
of those things
the way they win is to cheat at
elections they cheat like dogs they
cheat like dogs dogs don't cheat Donald
Trump we know his relationship with our
canine friends is clearly very scrambled
but dogs don't really cheat dogs
actually are very much the opposite okay
Trump then suggests that China infected
uh the U.S with covid
to punish us because of the tariffs that
Trump put on China which of course Trump
still doesn't understand are actually
paid by American companies the American
companies pay the tariffs when they
import Chinese Goods we save many
Industries we took in hun
Dred tariffs and taxes from China they
did not
that's why a lot of people said I wonder
why covet came here I wonder why that's
another it's another conspiracy theory
the reason covet came here I mean okay
fine it started in China
and then it went to Italy and then it
went to London and that okay eventually
it got here it was sent by China through
many other countries as punishment for
tariffs which our own companies paid
it's economics guys don't you understand
what's so confusing about that uh Trump
then lies and this is part of like the
lurid Stories part of his rallies Trump
lies that Democrats support abortion
after birth what who has ever said that
no one but there
tree in the world that wants what these
crazy people want they are radical they
want to rip except it's all not true
babies from the wombs remember during
the debate with crooked Hillary Clinton
I said they want to rip the baby from
the womb even in the ninth month
Michigan you need to dump this wild eye
extremist Gretchen Whitburn Whitmer is
going to win and of course there are
essential statistically there are almost
no abortions in the ninth month talk to
OB gyns I've done it we've done it on
the show we've talked about it
essentially does not happen if a woman
comes in at you know 38 weeks pregnant
and says I think I want an abortion what
you think OB GYN scope sure have an
abortion uh and then of course the the
post-birth thing is just completely
fabricated Trump then says that they
presumably Democrats I guess want to see
him in prison I think they'd like to see
me in prison can you imagine I think
that like you know why you know why
because they're sick they're sick sick
people
um one of the things that's interesting
is these Republicans love to say they
are for Law and Order all the time they
say it we're for Law and Order we're for
Law and Order
my position as someone on the left is
not I want to see Trump in prison I'm
out for blood it's if there is evidence
that Trump should be charged then charge
him
and then if he is convicted sentence him
appropriately and maybe that'll include
prison time that's Law and Order
okay not what they claim Trump then sort
of waxes poetic about authoritarian
Chinese president XI where he talks
about how great it is that he's just
killing drug dealers much of the crime
wave is caused by drug dealers who
during their lives will kill an average
of 500 American citizens think of it
think of it and I tell the story I'll
tell it quickly but when I was dealing
with China
when I was dealing with Russia
and I was dealing with all these
countries I got to know him all well and
I asked president XI they have 1.5
billion people
and they'd say is he smart I say yes
he's smart then the Press would say he's
saying president she is somebody is the
ruler of 1.5 billion he's smart very
smart beyond smart I said president do
you have a drug problem anyway then he
tells the story of how she told him that
they execute the drug dealers and they
have like a hundred percent conviction
rate when I hear about a hundred percent
conviction rate I start wondering is
that really a fair justice system but
Trump is completely enamored by it then
we get to the big finish which now
includes a sort of Q Anon music backdrop
uh this is now a regular part of these
rallies in the history of the world
[Music]
I have not added this music last time
some of my viewers thought I added the
music this they are now doing this at
the rally
[Applause]
[Music]
but now
we are a nation in Decline
we are a failing Nation
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation in 50 years so anyway why is
it that the Cults never have good music
I've noticed that there's the music's
always so weird
um we laugh to avoid crying because this
is really really disturbing and it sort
of gets awkward at one point during this
musical portion of the speech when Trump
talks about brutal murders he he loves
using these lurid examples of violence
to whining about flight cancellations
which of course don't affect him since
he flies private and it's all really
awkward thieves are allowed to go into
stores
and openly Rob them beat up the help and
killed people they will kill people and
they kill them at will if necessary and
even if not necessary
and there is no retribution they're
doing necessary and unnecessary killings
well if they're necessary are they
really evil what does that even mean
very we are a nation whose once revered
airports are a dirty crowded mess where
you sit and wait for hours and then are
notified that the plane won't leave
and they have no idea
when they will as a nation Trump also is
furious that he has not gotten credit
for some of his recent flights to his
frequent flyer miles when they will be
delivered and when you will be delivered
to your destination it's all right I
can't I can't do any more of it but it's
gone completely cult-like and an
extraordinarily dangerous and unhinged
speech the good news if there's any is
that a bunch of the people Trump is
supporting in Michigan seem to be
heading towards some pretty humiliating
losses one last really funny moment I
believe this was after the speech but
maybe it was before and again the speech
was in uh Michigan this guy Brian Glenn
who's one of the hosts on right side
broadcasting network this guy Brian has
been interviewing Trump for years all
over the country they go to Every rally
and Trump
talks to him about your Governor
Gretchen Whitmer as if he doesn't even
recognize that this is the same dude who
is not from Michigan and he's been
interviewing Trump dozens of times a
year look at this
end views of the people from Michigan
and your Governor's done a very poor job
as you know we've lost a lot of business
in Michigan they've lost a lot of jobs
in Michigan I think tutor is going to do
very well Mr President always a pleasure
so anyway Trump doesn't even seem to
know who he's talking about there scary
stuff but remember it's always scarier
that people follow this stuff and that's
what we're going to talk about next
uh Saturday night Trump rally in Warren
Michigan in support of Tudor Dixon and a
number of other Republican candidates
Trump dripping wet afraid we already
talked about that part let's look at
some video of the people who said I'm
gonna go to this rally here is a woman
who claims to teach economics I don't
know where her PhD in economics is from
or anything and she says she's telling
her students and again we don't know
where this is happening to buy gold and
silver band and so I just really do my
best in regards to teaching them about
economics showing them the value talking
about
silver and gold and precious metals
versus investing in the stock market no
supply and demand curves none of that
stuff uh gold coins because I say at the
end of the
value that you can take home
probably one of the most cited economic
scholars in the world and it's just my
ignorance where I have not heard of this
woman again unclear where she's teaching
economics there was a guy at the Trump
rally who it's whenever they mention
anyone who's gay like there's a comment
about Marjorie Taylor green mentioned
people that judge and she just can't
avoid a homophobic comment when she
mentions a gay person here is a guy who
mentions mentions Anderson Cooper and
again like makes just a weird homophobic
comment first Prime Minister in a
Catholic hardcore country and she won
with that much Landslide where is all of
them to be happy with it right nothing
zero zip silent CNN they don't say
anything and what's his name Anderson
Cooper He's a gay he's supposed to
support that no for women's right
Anderson Cooper is a gay as this
individual points out and therefore
Anderson Cooper should like the new
radical neo-fascist prime minister of
Italy because she's a woman and gay men
like women's rights quite a political
analysis from this gentleman really
interesting
um he also later was interviewed or
earlier who knows earlier later
um and said that it Jared kushner's
ability to solve problems is just
incredible
uh and remember Jared Kushner was
assigned by Trump to solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict and uh you
know we all know how that turned out one
woman that was interviewed by real
America's voice at the Trump rally over
the weekend she she threw herself at the
mercy of the audience apologizing
because she used to be on the left
listen to this I wanted to apologize to
humanity for voting for the Antichrist
Obama I deeply apologize
I was also pro-choice and I was an
atheist until January 21st and now she
seems to have a cross that she's wearing
so she went from being an atheist to
being a Christian 2021 I had a sudden
Awakening it was it was absolutely crazy
so I went from Blue to Red to Maga and
I'm here and I absolutely love it well I
want to tell you you don't have anything
to apologize for we all make mistakes in
our life and and that's where God's
grace comes in I mean that's the biggest
thing for me it is oh my gosh that's
amazing right I wrote about it on my sub
stack she's got a sub stack oh beautiful
you would believe me except my husband
was there when it happened it it
happened so suddenly and so amazing and
it was almost like a stroke it happened
so quickly it was just like a switch was
turned off there it is
like stuck into my brain and I just
started preaching out of nowhere it was
the most insane thing it sounds like it
absolutely sounds like it that's very
interesting couple other Clips here's
some people at the Trump rally with the
so-called election Integrity Force who
were trying to sign up so-called poll
Challengers to challenge votes and part
of what we're doing is tree uh teaching
classes and courses trying to credential
as many poll Challengers as we can by
the way credential it's such a that
that's an interesting term for what
they're trying to do quite a credential
they get so are you signing up folks
though that if they want to be a poll
Challenger they can
yes absolutely you can go to mc4ei.com
or electionintegrityforce.com and sign
up to be a whole challenging volunteer
we are credentialing people all over the
state so you don't have to be here uh in
Macomb or it's quite a credentialing
body that this guy is doing okay and
then lastly here's a woman who loves
that the Republican candidate Tudor
Dixon for governor in Michigan is
completely against all abortion this
woman loves it if she got
um uh a molested by a family member she
would keep her child and I'm right went
to it I would keep mine too so please do
not vote for tutor um give up on Twitter
because she's saying she does not want
abortions in Michigan's under no
exceptions I'm willing to um go even a
little bit extra and say that me and
tutor we will have discussions and I
will be sitting with her and we will
make a way because this is the way we
will do Planned Parenthood should be
working vigorously and effortlessly for
those abortion laws not uh Tudor Dixon
they they should get monies for these
women if abortions won't be in Michigan
then fly those women somewhere and get
them some help because no I do have
sympathy for people who's raped and
incest but Planned Parenthood should get
monies and send these women to another
outside State that's close Okay so I
guess what she's saying is
she's against any exceptions for rape
and incest but she's empathetic to
people to whom that happens
but fly them to a different state that's
very weird and extraordinarily scrambled
but it is what it is scary stuff at the
Trump rally and we will have all of
these clips on our Instagram which you
can find at davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright so
I teased this story earlier and I think
it's a really important one because it
is exactly the type of deception and
stochastic terrorism quite frankly that
will lead to real world violence the
headline that started floating around is
Democrats have started killing
Republicans Democrats are just murdering
Republicans and the questions are where
did that come from and where is this
supposedly happening well where it came
from is a republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Green speaking at the
Trump rally in war in Michigan over the
weekend uh Daily Beast covered it many
media Outlets covered it and the
headlines are something like Marjorie
Taylor green says Democrats have started
killings of Republicans let's listen to
what she had to say and as is often the
case actually should I explain now let's
play it first let's just play it and
then there's plenty to talk about here
we're all Targets now though for daring
to push back against the regime and it
doesn't stop at a weaponized legal
system by the way use of the word regime
to suggest that the Biden Administration
is anything other than a democratically
elected presidency
going to win
[Music]
girl boy was run down by a Democrat
driver who confessed to killing the
teenager simply because he was a
republican that's not true and I'll tell
you about it later
[Music]
even right here in Michigan just last
week an 83 year old woman was shot in
the back for advocating for The Unborn
that is also not true and I will tell
you about that story in a minute
[Music]
yeah Joe Biden has declared every
freedom loving American and Enemy of the
State but under Republicans we will take
back our country from the Communists who
have stolen it and want us to disappear
we will expose the unelected bureaucrats
the real enemies within who have abused
their power and declared political
Warfare all right so first of all there
there are no Communists that have taken
over Joe Biden's not a communist the
Communists and the Socialists really
don't like Biden because they say he's
basically just the Centrist of
Republican light capitalist okay so
there's no Communists here that's just
nonsense the rhetoric that Marjorie
Taylor green is using there is
completely unacceptable and it is very
dangerous because the lunatics in the
audience will hear it and they'll
believe it and then they might go go and
say well listen if the Democrats are
just killing Republicans on site then we
can do the same but understand that the
stories that Marjorie Taylor green told
aren't true she says a Democrat ran over
a republican because he was a republican
just ran him over with his car
what happened and you can Google the
story two morons more than likely got
into a political argument we don't know
whether alcohol or substances were a
factor but two people got into an
argument
it was an argument about politics the
argument escalated and one of them
jumped in his car and hit the other
person with his car
it was a Democrat who hit a republican
it's wrong it's a crime political
discussion should never escalate to that
should be charged should be punished if
convicted but Marjorie Taylor green
wants you to think some guy just drove
by someone with a Maga hat that he
didn't know and ran him over like it's
just some kind of Street assassination
this was a an argument that became a
fight that went crazy crimes were
committed punished the criminals but
it's not my neighbor's a Democrat I'm
gonna go run him over it didn't happen
Okay then she says an 83 year old woman
was shot for advocating for The Unborn
it's not what happened Okay Google the
story a man in Michigan was charged for
shooting an elderly woman in an
altercation that involved an accidental
shooting Richard Harvey is 74 years old
the story as far as we know right now is
that Joan Jacobson was campaigning
door-to-door in Michigan against
abortion that part is true
um Joan Jacobson came to the door of the
Harveys Harvey and his wife were arguing
they'd had a disagreement with the woman
who was going door-to-door arguing
against abortion
um and then at a certain point the guy
grabbed his uh what what are the details
here grabbed his uh rifle a 22 grabbed a
22. uh the rifle belonged to the guy's
wife and said hey you got to get out of
here you got to get out of here and
fired a warning shot at a tree now I
it's already wrong I'm already
completely against it okay then he says
that he quote without thinking tried to
hit the woman's clipboard out of her
hands with the rifle and at that point
he accidentally shot the woman so
negligent discharge should be charged
with a crime if the investigation
determines one was committed as I always
say but it was not a story The Way
Marjorie Taylor green paints it is there
was a pro-life event and a guy showed up
with a rifle and shot a pro-life
protester this was another one of these
alter K altercation confrontation things
I'm not defending them but they are not
the lurid assassinations I mean that
that Marjory Taylor green claims them to
be Trump does this a lot during his
speeches
Trump will tell stories like
uh we we just saw the conviction of an
illegal immigrant who was released into
the public and shot someone dead right
and then you look up the story and the
crime happened when Trump was President
yes now they were convicted but what
does it matter the crime happened when
Trump was President trying to make the
point that under Biden these things are
happening even though it happened under
Trump in some of these cases look up
every one of these and of course
extraordinarily dangerous because when
people on the right hear these stories
they become more likely on average to
act out in violent ways because they
believe that the left is doing it
extraordinarily dangerous stuff okay
last like side ancillary story from this
event that took place in Michigan this
Trump rally in Michigan which is just
completely and totally wild I do have a
couple of Mike pillow Clips here Mike
pillow also known as Mike Lindell the
CEO and founder of Mike pillow he was at
the Trump rally in Warren Michigan he
was interviewed by right side
broadcasting and he made the claim that
the FBI found him at the Hardys Where
They seized his phone because they
illegally put some kind of a tracking
device on him now does he have any proof
of this no he doesn't it's like one
o'clock or no like I guess 11 30. how
did they know where you were were they
following you no we have no idea
no we pulled into a heart as well how
did they know they tracked me illegally
they tracked my attracting device yeah
or my phone we don't know yet we're
trying to put it to the bottom of that
but what they did we just don't know you
know if they had a suspicion that pillow
was in town they probably just said
let's just wait at Hardee's he's
probably bound to show up eventually in
all seriousness isn't the tracking
device his phone like we all carry these
phones around and we mostly all have GPS
enabled I guess he's willingly carrying
it around until the FBI took it because
Mike pillow really not making too much
sense
um and then oh one more pillow clip from
the rally
here he was kind of jumping on the some
Republicans or bad train saying that the
Republicans nominated in Georgia aren't
good and by the way what he means by
that is that the Republicans in Georgia
weren't as willing as he wanted them to
be to try to just give George's
electoral votes to Trump even though
Biden won we're doing a class class
action lost
okay anyway here's the explanation I
don't care you know you got down in
Georgia you're stuck with those three
because they're Republicans yeah what's
better what's to me there's nothing
worse than evil evil doesn't show sides
right evil doesn't show um oh you're a
Republican or you're a Democrat no it
holds no bounds so you have the I
believe the worst three Republicans in
history down in Georgia ever ever and
because of the cover-up that they've
done and then here you yeah so what he
means is I would like them to have given
Trump Georgia even though Biden won it
that's effectively what Mike pillow is
saying here uh and then Meanwhile by the
way
if he's saying these three are the bad
candidates by definition it means that
Herschel Walker in Georgia must be a
good candidate which is laughable and
also really really scary so that's all
the stuff I want to talk about from
Michigan we heard from Trump we heard
from the audience members we heard from
Marjory Taylor green and now we heard
from Mike pillow you tell me who's the
scariest I I kind of lean towards it's
the audience because without the
audience none of these people get any
attention but because they have
followers they have influence and that
is truly truly sick stuff
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
I saw a super interesting headline this
morning about the U.S military and we've
talked about the US military so much on
this program it relates to foreign
policy it relates to budgetary
priorities it relates to culture in many
ways because there is this military
culture that exists in the United States
okay so what's the headline the headline
from the Army times is that the Army has
missed its recruiting goal by about 15
000 soldiers and as you read through the
article by Lolita balder from the
Associated Press you see that that 15
000 Soldier shortfall is about 25
percent of its recruitment gold this
year now at big companies when you miss
earnings projections by two percent it's
a pretty big deal so understand that
falling 25 percent short and the
military is a large organization falling
25 short of your recruitment goal for a
year uh is a really really big deal the
um article also points out that all
military services struggled in what
they're describing as a tight jobs
Market to find young people both willing
and fit to enlist uh adding while the
Army was the only service that didn't
meet its Target all others had to dig
deep into their pool of delayed entry
applicants which will put them behind as
they begin the next recruiting year on
Saturday
um the article to its credit says the
worsening problems stirs debate about
whether America's fighting force should
be restructured or reduced in size if
the services can't recruit enough and
also puts added pressure on National
Guard and reserves to help meet Mission
requirements so there's actually a bunch
of interesting layers to this
conversation first of all is just the
question why aren't as many people as at
times past applying or are the people
applying not meeting the relatively
modest
um but but still there uh requirements
for joining the military when it comes
to physical fitness and and health
conditions and this sort of thing one
really interesting aspect to this is
that wages are up in many sectors
including sectors that could be
alternatives to joining the military and
if you look at a wage and salary growth
in the United States this is a chart
looking at the last 25 years you see
that basically dating back to sort of
early in 2020 the pandemic quite frankly
there has been significant wage growth
in the United States now there are those
who will say this is a good thing
because people are making more some on
the right who often criticize lack of of
wage growth when there's a Democratic
president now say the wage growth is bad
because it's part of inflation which is
making it hard to hire people you know
the right is going to say it's bad no
matter what if a Democrat is in office
but let's be quite Frank and direct
about this
if you can make a better wage not
joining the military there are lots of
people who will choose to do the job
outside of the military or said a
different way when wages aren't as
oppressively low outside of the military
it's going to be bad for military
recruiting now there's also sort of
political reasons why folks might not be
jumping to sign up for the military at
this point in time look at someone like
Republican Congressman Matt Gates who
over the last week has been in a bunch
of viral video clips saying why don't we
get rid of the VA altogether the
Veterans Affairs Department
and of course you might believe that he
really wants to improve care for
veterans by getting rid of the VA and
doing it a different way but for the
most part veterans like the VA and it's
probably not helping recruiting that you
have even Republicans who are supposedly
always for the military and Veterans uh
openly hostile to some of the aspects of
uh of of the military World which
includes the VA
um and saying we should we should get
rid of that we have the stories of
female service members regularly
assaulted and worried that if they
report the assault within the military
they will be sent for a psych eval maybe
deemed unfit for service and they are
the ones who will Who will suffer rather
than the person they accuse of
assaulting them but that's just the kind
of nitty-gritty of why might we be
seeing this problem and of course you
can also make the claim although I don't
have data on
um that maybe
people who were targeted by the military
to join aren't seeing it as a valiant
Mission compared to at times past we
know recruiting after 9 11 went Sky High
because so many people thought if I
joined the military now I'm going to be
able to do something to stop or hurt the
people that did 911 then they were sent
to Iraq which had nothing to do with 9
11 and the rest is history but that's
not the story for today but there's a
whole other aspect to this which is it
should make us ask the question why does
the military need to be so big uh and we
can talk about big in terms of what it
costs but also huge militaries can cause
foreign policy blunders and we we've
seen this in the past if you look at
stories from the Korean War Vietnam to
some degree when you have a really big
military it can make one believe that it
is even more powerful and invulnerable
and you make military decisions that go
above and beyond even the power that you
have and it can lead to very bad
military decision decisions create
Quagmire's
endless uh sort of like a constant
rotation of loss of life it's kind of
what's happening to the Russian military
in Ukraine right now they do have the
stronger military but they overstated in
their own minds even the strength and so
there's lots of geopolitical reasons why
having a big military isn't necessarily
the best thing and of course if you're
someone like me a progressive Social
Democrat I want I'm not for abolishing
the military but I I recognize there are
threats to the United States the U.S
should have a military but it shouldn't
be nearly as large and far-reaching as
the one we have is and so much of the
money that is spent on defense could be
better spent elsewhere
I won't give you the full rant of all
the areas in which it could be spent but
I have many clips and stories about that
so needless to say the military
struggling to recruit what comes next
and and to be clear
this has nothing to do with Joe Biden
there are I saw anecdotally on Twitter
people saying this is because Biden has
disgraced the country so no one wants to
serve there's no evidence of that
whatsoever I also saw this is because of
Joe Biden's student loan debt relief
because one of the reasons people were
joining the military was because they
needed money to pay off their student
loans first of all that debt relief was
only just announced and that couldn't
possibly be the reason why in the last
year there was a shortfall in recruiting
and number two you're sort of saying
like we need to keep people really
desperate financially so that they'll
join the military that's not really that
doesn't speak wonders about the American
military if that's what it takes let me
know your thoughts I don't know that
this problem is going to Abate anytime
soon Republicans and right-wingers are
again Furious about candy
now if this rings a bell
it's because Tucker Carlson was Furious
about candy not that long ago check out
this clip from oan where they are
Furious that M Ms have gone woke by
introducing a purple Eminem
representing
inclusiveness and acceptance isn't that
just terrible right M M's you know the
candy we all grew up eating well they
released their brand new character in
over a decade and the brand new
character is purple Eminem which is
supposed to represent inclusivity and
acceptance
I think it's a female character but I'm
pretty sure they haven't said maybe it's
transgender joining me now there you go
for a very big explosive reaction to the
new Eminem's thing they focus on the
dumbest things because they completely
lack an interest and ability to talk
about actual policy issues there was
recently a headline I'm not covering I
don't know that it's a story in and of
itself but I saw a headline this morning
about how in 2017 Barack Obama was
telling uh Democrats that there's really
just no policy there's not even a
semblance of policy from Republicans
that the party is essentially a joke
that's my word not Barack Obama's and
this has been increasingly the case for
a while and these are when we say social
issues it's gone beyond social issues
it's not even about like abortion and
gay marriage anymore it's about Eminem's
and again if it rings a bell Tucker
Carlson also had a story back in January
it feels like it's been years but it was
only about 10 months ago where Tucker
was upset that the androgynous design of
M Ms was no longer turning him on quite
frankly remember this lunacy finally we
don't usually give story tips to NPR but
here's a story they might want to cover
pretty soon in doubtless will Eminem's
the candy company has just announced
that it's redesigning its cartoon
characters to be more gender inclusive
[Music]
come on
foreign
[Music]
s were pushing intolerance but they were
they've been changed they're seeing the
changes right now on your screen the
green m m you will notice is no longer
wearing sexy boots now she's wearing
sensible sneakers why the change well
according to M M's quote we all win when
we see more women in leading roles
because leading women do not wear sexy
boots leading women to wear frumpy shoes
the frumpier the better that's the rule
the other big change is that the brown
Eminem has quote transitioned from high
stilettos to lower block heels also less
sexy that's progress M Ms will not be
satisfied until every last cartoon
character is deeply unappealing and
totally androgynous until the moment you
wouldn't want to have a drink with any
one of them that's that's the goal when
you're totally turned off we've achieved
Equity Tucker for a long time was really
turned on by the design of M M's and all
of a sudden they are no longer turning
him on which is a really sad thing and
woke has won apparently guys they are
focused on the dumbest things and it is
not
a glitch it is a feature not a bug
they know there's no policy left they
know they're losing on policy you ask
the American people hey should the rich
be taxed in order to ensure that nobody
Falls below a certain level of standard
of living most people agree with that
that's not good for policy when it comes
to these Republicans so instead they
talk about I'm no longer turned on by
Eminem's because of woke people that
that's that's where we are and it's not
stopping anytime soon we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David P here's an interesting voicemail
a guy recounted a conversation he had
with someone he works with I believe
and there is such misunderstanding among
right Wingers about such basic things
listen to this voicemail and then we'll
discuss it okay
well David this is Bob from Texas yeah
uh I was having a conversation with a
co-worker or my manager I should say and
he was saying he was complaining about
um the coveted relief
and saying that it affected his 401k and
how much he you know could put into it
or something like that
and oh man and I explained I told them
well Trump did two of them and you know
you should be doubly mad at him right
instead of Bison you know and and I just
had I know I should probably do some
research on my own but
how does how does the covered relief
funds affect 401k and I know you're a
big Finance guy you may have some
insight on it yeah so listen here's the
first of all
a ton of the P so Trump has started
saying this at his rallies your 401ks
are doing terribly because of Biden what
does that really mean it's the stock
market okay when people talk about a
401k a 401k holds the same types of
assets anybody might hold directly so
it's stocks stock mutual funds Bond
mutual funds so we what they're really
saying is 401K balances go up and down
when the stock market goes up and down
so understand that the when they talk
about 401K what they really mean is the
stock market okay
what some right-wingers have claimed is
that covid relief packages
increased inflation and therefore pushed
down the value of the stock market so as
the caller points out if you're mad at
Biden for doing that with one coveted
relief package you should be doubly mad
at Trump for doing it with two the
reality is that the effect of those
coveted relief packages on global
markets in the American Market overall
is quite limited but I actually think
that's not even the right conversation
to have the right conversation is zoom
out and think for a second does the
stock market tend to do better when
there's a Democratic president or a
Republican president and the data are
clear the stock market on average does
better under democratic presidents now
the last couple months haven't been good
under Joe Biden
let's wait and see what happens at the
end of his term it is not always the
case but it is usually the case that
stocks do better under democratic
presidents when stocks do better 401K
accounts do better let's wait until Joe
Biden's term is actually complete we're
not even two years in at this point in
time and by the way look up all of this
stuff on your own unemployment tends to
be lower under democratic presidents GDP
growth tends to be higher job creation
tends to be higher there tend to be
fewer or there have been fewer
recessions under democratic presidents
even accounting for the difference in
number of years of democratic for
Republican presidents look it up
yourself and then ask about causation
correlation and then we can have a real
serious discussion but these confused
statements don't do much for any of us
we've got a great bonus show for you
today I'm out of time but sign up at
joinpakman.com we've got a doozy of a
bonus show for you and producer Pat
Joyner
foreign